on parler de chall surs et de Gill
platraay lilon on emraille tout de suite
avec la situation en et noir donc bah
tout de suite effectivement Gill
platraay vous vous êtes avec nous ce
soir c'était
1983 vague bleue Dominique Perben prend
la ville de chalonursun à la gauche 2014
est-ce que vous considérez que Chalon
est un symbole c'est un symbole d'une
campagne de terrain je pense d'ailleurs
qu'il y a des similitudes avec 83
j'avais 10 ans à l'époque je peux pas me
référer à des souvenirs personnels mais
c'est une campagne de terrain qui qui
s'est fondé absolument pas sur des
enjeux nationaux on avait l'occasion
d'en discuter lors du débat que vous
aviez organisé sur place mais sur des
enjeux locaux qui tenait à la
circulation aux impôts et également à
l'emploi qui va mal sur le secteur donc
on a mené cette campagne on l'a mené
dans l'Union c'était important aussi de
le dire c'était un élément moteur dans
dans cette victoire je pense et c'est un
discours et des thématiques qui se sont
imposé tout au long de la campagne
depuis le mois de novembre en fait
depuis qu'on a commencé et en même temps
christop CUG il est vice-président de
l'Assemblée nationale tion très marqué
politiquement est-ce que ça joue un rôle
moi je pense qu'il y a eu effectivement
des considérations nationales c'est ENF
ça me paraît imparable d'un autre côté
on a vraiment fait campagne sur des
enjeux locaux et comme on a entrepris
une grande campagne de consultation
parce que ça s'est fait vraiment près du
terrain du porte à porte 24000 portes
des réunons de quartier 26 donc on a on
a jamais entendu une aspiration à voir
les thèmes nationaux prendre le pas sur
les débats locaux donc c'est pour ça que
je dis oui bien sûr il y a un nationale
qui d'ailleurs s'emplifie à l'échelle de
la France tout entière ce soir on le
voit bien mais pour Chalon surs il y
avait je pense majorité une grande
majorité de thématiques locales qui sont
imposées dans le débat